Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. La semaine dernière, j'ai publié un épisode qui était assez clivant, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
J'ai à la fois eu des réactions hyper positives, des gens qui étaient ravis d'entendre ce que Corine Torrekens avait à dire sur les musulmans.
Et inversement, j'ai aussi reçu des messages de personnes très agacées, des auditeurs et des auditrices très fidèles jusque-là, qui m'expliquaient qu'ils allaient passer leur tour pour cet épisode.
Clairement, c'était un sujet sensible. Politiquement, culturellement, c'est un sujet qui divise beaucoup. Cette semaine, je crois que ce sera encore plus le cas.
J'ai eu la chance de me rendre chez le professeur Jacques Balthazart, qui est neuroendocrinologue et professeur émérite à l'Université de Liège.
On a discuté ensemble de choses comme de l'orientation sexuelle, des différences entre les femmes et les hommes, le tout du point de vue d'un biologiste.
Alors, avant de se lancer dans l'interview, je vais juste me permettre de poser un peu le contexte. Il y a très certainement parmi vous des gens qui sont des féministes constructivistes convaincus.
Et même chose, il y a aussi sûrement des gens qui ont des opinions plus conservatrices en la matière. Y a un point sur lequel je pense que tout le monde tombera d'accord.
Quand on parle du monde académique francophone, il y a encore et toujours un très grand attachement pour les thèses psychanalytiques, pour par exemple expliquer l'homosexualité,
pour expliquer les différences entre les sexes ou encore pour analyser l'autisme.
On en parlait d'ailleurs avec Julie Dachez l'an dernier. Et un autre point qui est intéressant, c'est que souvent en francophonie et plus particulièrement en France, on n'aime pas trop parler de la biologie.
C'est même quelque chose qu'on associe plutôt au nazisme, à l'extrême droite, à l'eugénisme et ainsi de suite. Et du coup, chers auditeurs, chères auditrices, en publiant cet épisode aujourd'hui, mon but, c'est d'informer.
Que vous soyez plutôt conservateur ou plutôt féministe, que vous adhériez ou non à ce que dit le professeur Balthazart, mon espoir, c'est que, à l'issue de cet épisode,
vous ayez tous et toutes une meilleure connaissance de ce que dit aujourd'hui la science en la matière.
À titre perso, moi, j'estime par exemple que les explications biologiques sont un des meilleurs arguments pour lutter contre l'homophobie.
Parce que, tout d'un coup, grâce à la science, les gens comprennent que c'est pas plus étrange, c'est pas moins naturel que l'hétérosexualité.
Et ils sont alors
moins effrayés par la différence. Vaincre les ténèbres par la science. J'étais très heureux que Jacques Balthazart accepte mon invitation et en l'annonçant autour de moi, j'ai effectivement constaté une certaine méfiance, une posture
un peu défensive pour dire : "Euuuh, mais tu sais Guillaume,
la biologie, c'est aussi une science située.
Vraiment, il faut être prudent, il faut se méfier de ces discours", tout ça. Alors oui, c'est vrai, mais je tiens à vous rassurer d'emblée,
mon invité n'est absolument pas un immonde masculiniste qui veut casser du féministe et c'est même plutôt le contraire, je pense.
Simplement, au cœur de sa cause, il y a la volonté de rappeler que : "Hé, OK, on éduque les filles et les garçons différemment.
OK, tout ça, c'est arbitraire et construit, mais les différences biologiques, elles sont là, elles existent et elles expliquent beaucoup de choses aussi."
Vous avez été super nombreux à m'envoyer vos retours positifs suite à l'épisode en octobre dernier avec Olivia Gazalé, où on abordait ensemble des questions relatives au genre, au féminisme, à la virilité, à la misogynie,
avec une approche plutôt constructiviste.
Et elle concluait d'ailleurs notre échange en précisant qu'il ne fallait pas pour autant ignorer les différences biologiques entre les sexes.
Pour moi, ce sont vraiment deux épisodes qui se complètent à merveille et j'espère que celui-ci vous plaira tout autant.
C'est parti. Je suis aujourd'hui en compagnie de Jacques Balthazart. Jacques Balthazart, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour les auditeurs qui ne vous connaissent peut-être pas ?
Oui, alors, je suis donc biologiste. J'ai fait des études qui s'appelaient la zoologie à l'époque, dans les années 70.
Et puis je me suis très rapidement intéressé au comportement et puis à son contrôle hormonal. Et donc je suis devenu, par pratique, neuroendocrinologue du comportement.
J'étudie les effets des hormones sur le cerveau dans la mesure où elles contrôlent le comportement. Je suis professeur émérite à l'Université de Liège, donc je continue une activité scientifique, mais je suis retraité depuis cinq ans maintenant.
Très bien. Mais oui, mais donc vous êtes, comme vous le disiez, un neuro-
Neuroendocrinologue. C'est un peu difficile, ça a l'air d'être un gros mot, mais ça l'est pas.
Un mot un peu barbare. Mais donc, je vais essayer d'arriver à le dire. Vous êtes neuroen-endocrinologue. Mais donc vous vous spécialisez visiblement dans des sujets qui sont plutôt liés aux questions d'identité sexuelle,
d'orientation sexuelle, de genre.
Alors ça, c'est un développement relativement récent dans ma carrière. En fait, ça date de 10 ans maintenant, mais comme j'ai 45 ans de carrière derrière moi, c'est récent, c'est tout, tout est relatif.
En fait, mon activité scientifique principale a consisté à étudier les effets des hormones sexuelles, donc la testostérone, l'œstradiol, sur le comportement en utilisant des modèles animaux.
Alors, j'ai, par intérêt personnel essentiellement, largement utilisé des oiseaux. Donc, j'ai fait beaucoup de travail sur le canard et puis sur la tourterelle, sur la caille, pas la jolie perdrix, le canari.
Et je me suis intéressé dans ce cadre-là à savoir comment les hormones activaient les comportements chez l'adulte, mais aussi comment elles le différenciaient pendant la vie embryonnaire ou la vie immédiatement postnatale. Donc, on sait que-
Oui, juste-
Oui, les hormones ont des effets irréversibles sur le comportement à ce moment-là et c'est très important-
On aura l'occasion-
Dans ce dont on va parler, oui
...on aura l'occasion de se plonger au cœur, voilà, de toute la technique hormonale, génétique, épigénétique liée à toutes ces questions.
Mais avant de s'intéresser à tout ça, peut-être pour reposer un peu le contexte, à titre personnel, qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à vous intéresser à ces questions-là ?
Oui, c'est un cheminement relativement long et indirect. Bon, si on veut, si on a un peu de temps. En fait, j'ai commencé par m'intéresser au comportement.
C'est le comportement qui m'intéressait et je l'ai étudié de façon relativement descriptive. Et puis après un an ou deux, je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas très satisfaisant parce que décrire les choses, c'était pas suffisant pour moi.
Je voulais entrer dans la boîte noire qu'est le cerveau et comprendre comment ça fonctionnait.
J'ai eu l'occasion, enfin mon patron de thèse à l'époque, Ernest Skov Nils, m'a proposé d'étudier les effets des communications phéromonales, c'est-à-dire les communications par odeur chez les oiseaux.
C'était relativement iconoclaste à l'époque, dans la mesure où on pensait que les oiseaux n'avaient pas d'olfaction, ce qui est tout à fait faux d'ailleurs.
Nous l'avons démontré depuis. Et puis, après quelques mois de cette étude, je travaillais sur des canards à l'époque qui ont une reproduction saisonnière.
Ils se reproduisent uniquement au printemps et je me suis retrouvé à l'automne avec des canards totalement inactifs et je ne savais plus quoi faire de mon temps.
Et je me suis dit : « Bah, si j'injectais mes mâles de testostérone, peut-être qu'ils réacquéreraient de l'activité sexuelle.
Et à partir de là, je pourrais de nouveau étudier leurs préférences pour les odeurs femelles ou non. » Et puis les expériences testostérone ont marché beaucoup mieux que les autres.
Et donc je me suis focalisé sur les effets de la testostérone et je suis donc devenu endocrinologue par rebond essentiellement, mais...
Mais donc vous êtes arrivé sur ces questions-là vraiment par un chemin fondamentalement, ouais, une démarche fondamentalement scientifique.
C'était une question, un questionnement fondamental sur le fonctionnement du comportement-
Oui
...et du cerveau.
Particulièrement des canards, oui.
Et particulièrement des canards à l'époque, mais ça, c'était le modèle-
Oui
...le modèle
animal qui était choisi à ce moment-là et j'ai changé de modèle animal en fonction des questions étudiées. Et puis alors évidemment, la question qui se pose en permanence aux chercheurs fondamentaux comme ça, c'est à quoi est-ce que tout ça sert ?
Bon, chaque fois que j'explique ce que je fais, on me dit : « Oui, mais à quoi est-ce que ça sert ? » Eh ben, ça sert à se poser des questions sur la nature humaine et voir si ces mécanismes-
Ouais
...qu'on met en évidence chez l'animal sont aussi présents chez l'homme. On m'a demandé aussi dans le cadre de la faculté de psychologie de donner un cours sur les hormones et comportements chez l'homme.
Et donc c'est à partir de ce moment-là que j'ai commencé à amasser des données de la littérature sur l'homme quoi.
Mais donc c'est intéressant. C'est-- comprendre l'homme, c'est toujours la finalité de votre travail.
Non.
Ben, c'est ce que vous avez dit à l'instant.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on me demande toujours, mais ce n'est pas la finalité de mon travail. La finalité de mon travail, c'est comprendre en fait.
Je suis curieux-
Oui
...et j'ai envie de savoir comment ça marche, que ce soit le comportement animal ou tout autre chose d'ailleurs. Mais bon d'abord, c'est une question qu'on vous pose toujours, c'est à quoi est-ce que ça sert.
Et donc ça sert à comprendre l'animal et éventuellement même à contrôler sa reproduction, etc. Mais ce n'est pas mon intérêt non plus.
Ça sert, de base, à la recherche biomédicale, mais c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse, mais ce n'est pas mon primum movens.
Et l'autre chose, évidemment, c'est que pour faire de la recherche, il faut trouver des sous. Et pour trouver des sous, il faut justifier les raisons sociétales qui-
D'accord
...guident votre recherche. Et donc c'est une des justifications des demandes de crédit que je fais encore maintenant pour travailler sur la caille et sur le canari.
Nous sommes encore actuellement financés par deux crédits du NIH, donc du département de la santé américaine, en collaboration avec un collègue américain, pour étudier le comportement sexuel de la caille et le comportement de chant du canari.
Mais le département de la santé, donc la recherche biomédicale américaine, ne me finance pas pour étudier le canari.
Elle me finance pour étudier la plasticité neuronale et les mécanismes qui contrôlent cette plasticité parce que ça pourrait servir d'indicateur sur des mécanismes humains et éventuellement-
Ouais
...aboutir à de la recherche biomédicale.
Donc c'est la motivation, disons, du système académique, des financements qui sont disponibles, mais peut-être pas tellement la vôtre.
Mais ce n'est pas tellement la mienne, encore que ça l'est devenu parce que les intérêts de-- on n'est pas non plus totalement fixé dans ses intérêts.
Mon intérêt premier, c'est la compréhension du système chez l'animal éventuellement, mais il est bien évident que la question de savoir si ça s'applique à l'homme m'intéresse également profondément.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que vous arrivez donc sur ces questions, voilà, par un long cheminement intellectuel, hein, l'étude des canards au fil des années.
Et vous arrivez maintenant, donc c'est il y a dix ans maintenant-
Oui
...avec un livre qui s'appelait Biologie de l'homosexualité. On naît homosexuel, on ne choisit pas de l'être.
À une époque où ces questions-là sont non pas des sujets
réservés aux biologistes et aux neuroendocrinologues, mais des sujets qui sont sur toutes les lèvres dans notre société, au niveau politique, au niveau académique, au niveau psychologique et ainsi de suite.
Donc, vous débarquez un petit peu dans un nid de guêpe, dans un sujet intellectuel périlleux. Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ?
Oui, dans une certaine mesure. Bon, en fait, je suis donc intéressé par le sujet depuis pas mal d'années. Je vais chaque année à
deux conférences au moins aux États-Unis où je rencontre des gens qui travaillent comme moi sur les oiseaux, les rats, les souris,
mais aussi qui travaillent chez l'homme.
Donc, je connais personnellement un bon nombre de gens qui travaillent sur des problèmes de sexualité humaine.
Et puis alors, je donne cours donc en faculté de psychologie sur les hormones et comportements chez l'homme, puisque les psychologues s'intéressent relativement peu aux animaux, encore qu'on est obligé de leur expliquer les bases animales pour
comprendre tout.
Et je n'avais pas vraiment de vocation à écrire des bouquins, parce que j'écris des articles scientifiques, mais pas des bouquins.
Et puis, en fait, ce qui a déclenché mon écriture, c'est un livre qui a été publié en 2006 alors par un pédopsychiatre parisien qui s'appelle Stéphane Clerget et qui s'appelait Comment on devient homosexuel.
Alors, dans la préface de son livre, il nous expliquait qu'il allait réconcilier les domaines de la biologie et de la neurobiologie moderne avec les données de la psychanalyse.
Et en fait, pendant les deux cents pages de son bouquin, il ne faisait qu'une chose, c'est démolir tout ce qu'il y avait de biologique et faire l'éloge de la psychanalyse.
Mh.
Alors ça m'a profondément énervé. Et ma femme m'a dit : « Ben si t'es tellement énervé, ben t'as qu'à écrire un bouquin toi-même, essentiellement. »
Et donc c'est ce que j'ai fait. J'ai commencé à écrire un bouquin sur base des cours que j'avais déjà donnés en psycho et j'ai commencé à écrire un bouquin qui s'adressait à
la mécanique, aux mécanismes biologiques qui contrôlent l'orientation sexuelle chez l'homme.
Étant entendu qu'il y avait déjà à l'époque énormément de données, d'articles scientifiques, des centaines ou au moins sept, huit cents qui parlaient de ces mécanismes biologiques essentiellement.
Alors, ça démontrait pas tout, mais ça présentait en tout cas très clairement l'idée que la biologie était à la base de l'orientation sexuelle en grande partie, si pas en totalité.
Oui. Et donc cet auteur, rappelez-moi son nom.
Alors, il s'appelle Stéphane Clerget.
Stéphane Clerget, qui est donc un auteur-
Parisien
...parisien
Il est parisien, il est français. Il continue à écrire d'ailleurs sur des tas de sujets. Il s'est encore fait entendre sur les antennes de France 2, je pense, il y a quelques semaines,
pour dire que l'homosexualité n'était pas un choix, mais que la biologie n'avait rien à voir dans le phénomène.
Donc ça m'a encore de nouveau conforté dans mes idées.
D'accord. Mais je mets l'accent donc sur l'origine de ce monsieur, donc Paris, la France. Peut-être mettre l'accent sur une différence, oui, entre
une culture franco-française qui n'aime pas du tout les questions de déterminisme génétique.
Est-ce que c'est votre sentiment ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous avez pu observer ?
Oui, oui, non, il est très clair qu'il y a une résistance majeure en France à accepter l'idée qu'une variable biologique, quelle qu'elle soit, que ça soit la génétique, que ça soit les hormones, pourrait influencer le comportement humain. Alors, je sais pas
pourquoi. Y a plusieurs raisons potentielles, mais l'idée que nos comportements seraient en partie déterminés par la biologie leur est absolument considérée comme horrible en France,
alors que dans les cultures anglo-saxonnes que je fréquente beaucoup plus, évidemment, puisque ma recherche,
toute la recherche est publiée en anglais et mon domaine de recherche est très largement un domaine développé aux États-Unis, donc je vais très régulièrement aux États-Unis.
Ben là, les idées contrôle par l'environnement, contrôle par la sociologie, etc., existent, mais elles sont en balance au moins égale avec les idées disant : « Ben la biologie fait quelque chose ».
Et c'est toujours un peu des deux, évidemment. C'est jamais inné ou acquis, c'est jamais environnemental ou biologique pur, c'est jamais intrinsèque, extrinsèque.
Mais en France, tout ce qui est contrôle biologique a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à passer. On accepte la génétique de la couleur des yeux et des cheveux, mais dès qu'il est question
de parler, par exemple, de génétique du quotient intellectuel, c'est
l'horreur.
Oui, c'est ça. Et bon, alors là, on sort un petit peu de la biologie pure, mais cette résistance en France à parler du déterminisme génétique, est-ce que vous savez l'attribuer à quelque chose ?
Est-ce que vous l'expliquez ?
C'est très difficile de savoir exactement d'où ça vient. Moi, je vois un certain nombre de possibilités. Il y a d'une part le fait que les universités françaises et l'intelligentsia parisienne a souvent très largement été de gauche.
Et en fait, la gauche refuse un petit peu ce qui est
intrinsèque à l'espèce humaine. Bon, les personnes naissent égales et donc la société doit pouvoir les modeler pour en faire exactement ce qu'elle veut, la société.
Évidemment, on naît égaux en droit, c'est incontestable, mais on ne naît pas égaux de fait. Et donc ça, c'est indiscutable, mais ça a pu jouer.
L'autre aspect qui joue, à mon avis, c'est la prééminence qu'a gardée la psychanalyse en France, notamment sous l'influence de Lacan et de Marie Bonaparte, qui ont été des disciples de Freud, avec qui ils se sont séparés.
D'ailleurs, Lacan s'en est séparé assez violemment à un moment donné. Mais la psychanalyse reste extrêmement implantée en France.
C'est à peu près le seul pays au monde avec l'Argentine où elle a encore une aussi grande influence. Et tout ça joue éventuellement aussi.
Il y a peut-être d'autres raisons qui m'échappent. Moi, je ne suis pas sociologue, je suis biologiste, évidemment. C'est un peu difficile de cerner ça, mais c'est très clair comme phénomène en tout cas.
Oui. J'ai effectivement le sentiment qu'il y a sans doute un rapprochement à faire avec cet universalisme républicain.
Voilà, on naît égaux, on naît tous pareils. Et puis finalement, je crois même que tout ce qui a trait aux différenciations génétiques et biologiques innées sont plutôt associés, je pense, en France, aux partis d'extrême droite.
À la droite et à l'extrême droite, oui, oui, bien sûr.
Oui, oui.
J'avais en fait repéré ces diabolisés. J'avais repéré un certain nombre de citations de Nietzsche qui auraient bien été pour faire des en-têtes de chapitres de mon premier livre.
Et en fait, un ami français m'a fortement déconseillé de les utiliser parce que Nietzsche n'était pas nazi lui-même, mais il a été très largement récupéré par le nazisme.
Et on m'a dit que ça allait associer mon bouquin au nazisme, ce qui n'était pas une bonne idée. Ceci étant, je me suis néanmoins fait traiter de nazi quand mon bouquin est sorti la première fois.
Mais d'un autre côté, j'ai aussi énormément de gens qui m'ont écrit pour me dire que ça les avait vraiment soulagés de lire ce que j'avais écrit.
Donc les avis sont très partagés.
Donc là, nous parlons de votre premier livre. Donc je rappelle le titre, c'est Biologie de l'homosexualité : on naît N A Î T homosexuel, on ne choisit pas de l'être.
Peut-être revenir sur ce premier livre avant de s'attaquer au second. Ce que vous développez comme propos dans ce premier livre, pour le résumer très vite fait et très maladroitement, c'est l'idée qu'il y a un facteur,
primordial, très important dans la question de l'orientation sexuelle qui est,
l'importance de certaines hormones sexuelles dans la période périnatale.
Est-ce que c'est bien résumé ?
C'est un des aspects importants en tout cas du bouquin. Donc, il y aurait une imprégnation par les hormones masculines, donc la testostérone essentiellement,
qui déterminerait, en partie, en tout ou en partie, alors ça, c'est très difficile à savoir, l'orientation sexuelle.
Il est très clair, évidemment, que les embryons et les fœtus masculins sont exposés à des taux élevés de testostérone, ce qui n'est pas le cas des fœtus féminins.
Cette testostérone a bien entendu chez l'homme des effets comme elle en a chez l'animal. Y a qu'à se pencher sur la différenciation des structures génitales, elle est entièrement sous dépendance de la testostérone embryonnaire.
Donc des effets d'une part dans le développement des organes, mais aussi au niveau comportemental.
Alors, on sait chez l'animal que cette testostérone embryonnaire a des effets irréversibles, on les appelle organisationnels, organisateurs, sur le cerveau et sur le fonctionnement du cerveau, c'est-à-dire sur le comportement.
Chez l'homme, évidemment, on ne peut pas faire les expériences qui permettraient de le démontrer de façon péremptoire, mais on a toute une série d'arguments plus ou moins directs qui montrent que les mécanismes mis en jeu chez l'animal
sont toujours présents chez l'homme, même s'ils sont éventuellement partiellement masqués par des phénomènes plus récents de développement de notre cerveau.
Donc le développement d'un cortex important, la volonté, le contrôle attentionnel, etc. Mais les motivations fondamentales restent contrôlées et restent différenciées sexuellement par l'effet de ces hormones prénatales.
Oui donc là, on parle vraiment de l'attraction sexuelle pour un partenaire.
On parle de l'attraction sexuelle. Alors il faut bien préciser ici que si on parle d'homosexualité dans mon livre et dans ce que je dis, je parle de l'attraction pour un partenaire ou un autre.
Je ne parle pas du fait d'avoir des comportements homosexuels, parce que ça, ça peut être très nettement contrôlé par les circonstances, soit fait la présence, l'absence du partenaire de sexe désiré, etc. Bon, on pourrait-
Oui donc là, ce serait sans doute effectivement plutôt du domaine de la psychologie, de l'étude du comportement, ainsi de suite, que de l'étude du cerveau profond.
Si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Oui, éventuellement, on peut dire que le fait d'avoir des comportements sexuels pourrait être contrôlé par les circonstances.
Et donc ça va être analysé par notre cerveau conscient. Il y a notre cerveau profond, moins conscient ou pas conscient du tout d'ailleurs, qui, lui, désire, définit ce qu'on désire en fait.
Et c'est ça, c'est cet aspect-là auquel je m'attache dans le livre. Le fait d'avoir,
de mettre en action son homosexualité, donc d'avoir des relations homosexuelles et le fait de le déclarer à la société, ça, ce sont des phénomènes conscients, évidemment,
qui ne sont pas contrôlés par les hormones, qui sont contrôlés par l'environnement et par notre cortex, donc par notre cerveau conscient.
Alors, vous expliquez aussi un phénomène intéressant qui est l'idée que
il y a des moyennes statistiques. Et donc là, on est encore toujours très prudents dans la façon dont on exprime ça, mais des moyennes statistiques qui indiquent qu'effectivement,
les personnes homosexuelles femmes sont surexposées par rapport à la moyenne aux hormones sexuelles mâles, donc la testostérone en l'occurrence.
Et pour les hommes, ce sera alors l'inverse, donc moins d'androgènes que la moyenne. Et que donc ça aurait, donc les conséquences dont il est question.
Mais ce ne sont pas les seules. Et donc vous expliquez un truc intéressant, c'est qu'il y a une corrélation avec la taille des doigts.
Oui, alors ça, c'est une des approches qui a été utilisée pour essayer de lier homosexualité et imprégnation hormonale prénatale.
C'est un des critères, des multiples critères, mais c'est celui qui attire en général l'attention de la grande presse.
Donc en fait, il y a-
C'est marrant hein
...dans l'espèce humaine, il y a une différence sexuelle à la moyenne entre la longueur du deuxième et du quatrième doigt.
Donc l'index et l'annulaire. Chez l'homme, l'index est plus court que l'annulaire, donc le doigt deux est plus petit que le doigt quatre, alors que chez la femme, ses doigts sont grosso modo de même longueur.
Alors, il ne s'agit pas d'une différence tout ou rien. Cette longueur des doigts ne permet pas d'identifier le sexe d'un individu à partir de la mesure de ses doigts.
Mais si on fait une étude sur cent ou deux cents personnes, on retrouvera à peu près toujours une différence statistiquement significative entre les hommes et les femmes.
Alors, on sait que cette différence est induite par la testostérone prénatale. Ça, ça a bien été démontré chez l'animal.
On a des exemples chez les amphibiens, les reptiles, les oiseaux et les mammifères. On a dix, quinze espèces où quand on traite un embryon avec de la testostérone, on raccourcit le deuxième doigt.
Donc ça, c'est bien connu. Dans l'espèce humaine, ça marche toujours parce que les filles qui ont été, à cause d'une maladie dont on reparlera peut-être, exposées à trop d'androgènes pendant la vie embryonnaire,
ces filles ont un doigt deux qui est plus court.
Et par contre, les garçons, les individus XY, mais qui ne sont pas sensibles à la testostérone parce que
le récepteur à la testostérone, donc la molécule qui lie la testostérone et lui permet d'agir au niveau cellulaire, a été muté et ne fonctionne plus, ben ces garçons naissent avec une morphologie de fille.
Donc ces XY naissent avec une morphologie de fille et ont des doigts de fille, c'est-à-dire des doigts avec le D2 et le D4 qui ont de même taille.
Donc, on sait que la longueur relative du doigt deux et du doigt quatre est affectée par la testostérone prénatale.
Et alors, on a pu montrer au cours de toute une série d'études que les femmes homosexuelles ont un doigt deux plus court que le doigt quatre.
En moyenne.
En moyenne. De nouveau, on ne pourra pas retrouver individuellement l'orientation sexuelle de quelqu'un à partir de la longueur de ses doigts, mais en moyenne, cet effet est présent et reproductible.
J'insiste donc sur le fait que c'est en moyenne et pas individuellement.
Mark Breedlove, qui est la première personne, le chercheur aux États-Unis, à l'Université de Michigan,
qui a démontré ça pour la première fois, a dit plusieurs fois dans des interviews, en boutade, que le seul moyen de savoir quelle était l'orientation sexuelle d'une personne, ce n'est pas de regarder ses mains, c'est de lui demander.
Et regarder autre chose.
Voilà. Donc, mais,
il est très clair qu'il y a un effet là qui est probablement, alors ça, on peut discuter de l'interprétation, mais il est probablement une indication d'une exposition supérieure à la moyenne, donc à la normale pour une femme,
à des taux de testostérone élevés.
Alors, je retiens qu'on va devoir parler donc de la maladie que vous évoquiez à l'instant. Ça, je n'oublie pas. Mais avant ça, le-- 'fin on a immédiatement envie de vous poser la question, mais cette exposition
surélevée par rapport à la normale, d'où est-ce que ça vient ?
Qu'est-ce qui provoque ce genre de différence pendant la période de gestation ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs réponses à ça évidemment. Dans le cas de la maladie spécifiquement dont je viens de parler, là, la cause est parfaitement bien connue en fait.
C'est une mutation de un des deux ou trois enzymes qui contrôlent la synthèse de cortisol dans les glandes surrénales.
Alors les glandes surrénales, c'est des petites glandes au-dessus des reins qui sécrètent le cortisol, qui est l'hormone de stress.
Peut-être juste rappeler alors de quelle maladie on parle, puisque comme ça, on sera plus clair.
Alors, on parle-- C'est de nouveau un mot qui va paraître un peu grossier. C'est l'hyperplasie congénitale des glandes surrénales. Donc hyperplasie-
Mais ça a le mérite d'être clair ouais
...hyperplasie, donc c'est le développement excessif. Congénital parce que c'est lié aux gènes et c'est lié à-- ça se produit dès le début de la vie, des glandes surrénales.
Alors si ces enzymes sont mutées, donc elles ne sont plus capables de faire du cortisol, la glande surrénale se met à produire par un mécanisme de compensation des androgènes, donc des hormones qui ressemblent à la testostérone.
Et donc ces individus vont être exposés, s'ils sont de sexe féminin, à des
taux très élevés de testostérone qui feront qu'éventuellement, à la naissance, dans les cas les plus graves, ces petites filles naîtront avec une morphologie génitale totalement masculine, donc avec un pénis et avec un scrotum-
Malgré leurs chromosomes XX.
Malgré leurs chromosomes XX. Donc elles sont génétiquement filles, mais elles sont masculinisées par la testostérone, ce qui est une des démonstrations les plus nettes des effets de la testostérone d'ailleurs.
Oui. Donc ça, c'est un cas. Est-ce que ce n'est pas aussi dans ce genre de scénario qu'on observe alors des jeunes, des nouveau-nés avec les deux organes sexuels ?
C'est quelque chose qu'on observe parfois.
Alors les deux organes sexuels externes, c'est impossible. Parce que en fait-
D'accord. Ou peut-être internes alors.
Alors internes, oui, externes, c'est impossible. Alors y a deux mécanismes de différenciation des structures sexuelles.
Au niveau externe, tout se développe à partir de la même structure. Donc y a un bourgeon génital et des replis autour d'une ouverture, d'une fente.
Et le bourgeon génital, sous l'influence de la testostérone et de son métabolite, d'ailleurs, la dihydrotestostérone, bon, mais on n'entrera peut-être pas dans ce détail-là, va grandir en pénis.
En l'absence d'hormones, il va se développer en clitoris. Donc le pénis et le clitoris sont exactement la même structure embryonnaire qui est exposée ou pas à la testostérone.
Par contre, au niveau interne, là, y a deux jeux de canaux embryonnaires qu'on appelle canaux de Wolff et canaux de Müller, qui vont donner soit d'un côté
les épididymes, donc les petits canaux qui vont transporter le sperme entre le testicule et le pénis,
soit vont donner, les canaux de Müller vont donner le vagin et l'utérus.
Alors ça, ça se développera l'un ou l'autre en fonction des hormones qui seront présentes. Et c'est en partie la testostérone, mais aussi en partie une autre hormone qu'on appelle l'hormone antimüllérienne. M'enfin bon-
D'accord, ok
...on n'a peut-être pas besoin d'entrer dans tout ce détail-là. Mais là, on peut avoir effectivement coexistence des deux types de canaux si quelque chose se produit qui est anormal au niveau du développement.
Mais au niveau externe, on est soit tout mâle, soit tout femelle, soit à moitié entre les deux, mais on ne peut pas être l'un et l'autre.
J'évoquais ça, même si c'est assez déconnecté du sujet principal, qui était l'orientation sexuelle, mais j'évoquais ça parce qu'il me semble avoir entendu que dans ces cas-là, on a tendance à ce moment-là,
faire des interventions chirurgicales pour corriger ça de manière assez...
Oui, alors
on fait des interventions chi-- on a fait d'ailleurs, parce que maintenant, c'est de plus en plus discuté et on pense arrêter totalement ce genre,
ce genre d'intervention, mais on a fait des interventions pour essayer de corriger, alors le corriger doit être mis entre guillemets, chirurgicalement, des structures génitales.
On le fait notamment dans le cas de ces petites filles avec hyperplasie des surrénales, donc qui naissent avec des structures génitales externes partiellement masculines ou totalement masculines.
Bon, sachant que ce sont des individus XX, donc génétiquement féminins, on fait une ablation partielle du pénis pour en refaire un clitoris
et on réouvre l'ouverture vaginale si elle était fermée, parce que parfois, l'ouverture est fermée pour faire un scrotum, on la réouvre.
Alors c'est ce qu'on appelle une vaginoplastie. Donc on refait des structures génitales. Ça se fait aussi dans des cas de malformation du bassin qu'on appelle les exstrophies cloacales,
où là, on refait des structures génitales féminines également,
quel que soit le sexe des embryons concernés, qu'ils soient XX ou XY.
Parce que, en tout cas, historiquement, c'est ce qu'on faisait, parce qu'il était très difficile chirurgicalement de refaire un pseudo-pénis, chirurgicalement.
Alors c'est plus facile de faire,
de faire un vagin. Et donc, on refaisait des structures génitales féminines. Ça a apporté, ça apporte toujours d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'informations concernant le déterminisme du sexe, aussi du sexe comportemental, puisque ces individus,
même s'ils sont XY, donc même s'ils sont de sexe génétique, ils ont été exposés à de la testostérone pendant leur vie prénatale, parce que leurs testicules sont normaux.
Mais on les a transformés en filles à la naissance et on se rend compte qu'à la puberté, ces individus redemandent à devenir des garçons et sont sexuellement attirés par les filles.
Redemandent au sens propre du terme, c'est-à-dire des personnes transsexuelles alors.
Alors, ils sont pas trans. Ils, enfin, on les avait rendus transgenres dans la mesure où on les avait féminisés, on les avait transformés en filles.
Et eux, en fait, résistent à ça et dans la grande majorité des cas, reviennent à leur identité et à leur orientation sexuelle masculine, c'est-à-dire une attraction pour les femmes.
Ce qui est un autre argument qu'on utilise pour dire que la testostérone prénatale a probablement eu un rôle, puisque dans ce cas-ci, l'éducation a été en tant que fille, mais ils se retrouvent hommes à l'âge adulte.
Donc ça veut dire que c'est pas l'éducation qui a dû le faire, ça doit être quelque chose d'autre. Et la seule chose à laquelle on puisse penser, ben c'est la testostérone prénatale.
Oui. Alors, je note que vous avez fait une équivalence entre identité masculine et attirance pour les femmes.
Donc ça, on aura l'occasion de revenir là-dessus dans un instant. Juste avant ça, donc vous disiez que la perception de cette malformation avait changé dans les années récentes.
Donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui, on ne fait plus cette opération chirurgicale,
C'est de plus en-- c'est en discussion, disons. Ce n'est pas quelque chose de clair.
Les techniques chirurgicales ayant évolué, on peut maintenant reconstruire un pénis
pas totalement fonctionnel, mais en tout cas au niveau morphologique, on peut construire quelque chose qui soit fonctionnel, peut-être pas au niveau sexuel, mais au niveau morphologique.
Et pour uriner, c'est tout à fait utilisable. Et donc on s'est rendu compte qu'y avait pas que la structure, que la composition des parties génitales qui était importante pour choisir le sexe d'un individu.
Enfin, on ne le choisit pas en principe, mais on est obligé, à un moment donné, quand y a un individu qui a une malformation, on est obligé, à un moment donné, de prendre une décision. Que va-t-on faire ?
Ben en fait, que se passerait-il si on ne prenait pas de décision et qu'on était juste passif par rapport à ça ? Qu'est-ce que...
C'est une des solutions qui est maintenant envisagée- ...demandée d'ailleurs par pas mal de gens des communautés LGBT
Qui disent : « Laissez-nous tels que nous sommes et si on veut changer quelque chose quand on sera adulte, ben on le changera à ce moment-là.
» Parce que évidemment-
Je pose la question parce qu'il y a un instant où vous disiez : « Nous sommes obligés de prendre une décision », mais
on se sentait obligés parce que la société considérait qu'on devait appartenir à un sexe ou à un autre.
Il y a de plus en plus de mouvements qui sont en train de dire : « Non, laissez tous les gens se développer comme ils veulent.
Et puis après, ben c'est eux qui choisiront. » Donc c'est une solution possible. Maintenant, il y a aussi des tas de gens, et notamment dans les communautés LGBT, qui ont tendance à dire que le sexe n'est pas quelque chose de binaire.
Je pense que c'est relativement une erreur parce que y a bien entendu un certain nombre de cas qui sont indécis, mais dans la grande majorité des individus, le sexe est binaire.
Et bon, la journaliste Peggy Sastre avait posté sur son Twitter récemment
une blague, enfin une blague, un bon mot qui disait : « Dire que le sexe n'est pas binaire, c'est comme prétendre que l'espèce humaine n'est pas bipède sous prétexte qu'il y a un certain nombre de gens qui ne savent pas marcher sur leurs deux pattes.
» Mais bon, en principe, on est bipède et on est binaire. Maintenant, il y a un certain nombre de cas qui posent question.
Est-ce qu'il faut les forcer dans un moule ou est-ce qu'il faut les laisser se développer tels qu'ils sont ? C'est une question qui est tout à fait ouverte pour le moment.
D'accord.
En fonction du médecin qu'on rencontrera, on aura des résultats différents.
Mais et le biologiste que j'ai en face de moi, est-ce qu'il a une opinion à ce sujet-là ? Est-ce que...
Je serais probablement plus tenté de dire laisser les personnes se développer comme ils veulent, mais ça pose aussi des problèmes parce que les problèmes d'intégration à l'école primaire, etc., sont difficiles.
Les enfants sont extrêmement cruels les uns avec les autres et donc garder des gens en sexe indéterminé, c'est une chose qu'on essaye de faire, même pour des gens qui n'ont pas de problème de différenciation sexuelle.
D'ailleurs, c'est une chose qu'on essaye de faire dans les pays scandinaves maintenant, utiliser des noms neutres, des pronoms neutres, etc.
C'est les néo, oui.
Je pense que ça va générer au moins autant de problèmes que ça va en résoudre, mais c'est difficile à dire.
C'est quelque chose qu'on entend souvent, c'est ce que les Anglo-Saxons appellent les theybies. Donc ce pronom neutre pour parler des personnes qui n'assignent ni un genre masculin ou féminin.
Il y a effectivement, très facile de l'imaginer, il y a un harcèlement scolaire assez violent par rapport à ces jeunes enfants-là, donc...
C'est des expériences en cours, je sais pas où elles vont mener.
Tout à fait. Donc c'est très, très compliqué. Mais donc si on en revient, parce que là, on a fait une petite digression à ce sujet-là.
Donc si on revient sur le sujet premier qui était l'orientation sexuelle. Donc, on a parlé alors à ce moment-là de l'impact hormonal sur l'orientation sexuelle chez les hommes, chez les femmes.
Je reviens sur ce que j'avais remarqué il y a un instant, que vous disiez donc qu'on faisait une équivalence entre l'identité masculine et l'attraction pour les femmes.
C'est finalement assez binaire comme-- parce que donc si effectivement, le sexe est tout à fait binaire, et là-dessus, je vous rejoins, voilà, XX ou XY, point, voilà.
'Fin, c'est même plus compliqué que ça parce qu'il y a des X0, il y a des XXY, il y a des XYY, etc. Mais enfin, en majorité, bon, si on exclut 1 ou 2 % de la population-
Mh.
...le sexe est binaire, il y a des XY.
2 %, ça me paraît même beaucoup.
Ça, ça pourrait être beaucoup. Maintenant, il y a un bon nombre de cas qui sont non détectés non plus. Donc on n'a pas non plus des statistiques très précises de ce que sont les individus avec une différenciation sexuelle
non conforme à ce modèle binaire, parce que c'est très compliqué.
Il y a beaucoup de cas qui paraissent, qui ne sont pas détectés. Il y a des cas qui sont extrêmement cryptiques.
Bon, on parlait tantôt des XY, donc des hommes qui n'ont pas de récepteur à la testostérone. Ben ces individus naissent en étant parfaitement féminins et ne sont quasiment jamais détectés à la naissance.
Il y a deux testicules qui n'ont pas pu descendre dans un scrotum puisqu'il n'y a pas de scrotum. Ils sont palpables sous la peau au niveau de la vulve, mais ils sont en général non détectés.
Et ce n'est qu'à la puberté que des filles viennent éventuellement consulter en disant : « J'ai pas de règles. » Et puis on fait une échographie, on se rend compte qu'à l'intérieur de l'abdomen, il n'y a pas un utérus, mais il y a deux testicules.
Et donc, s'il n'y a pas consultation médicale, ces individus vivront toute leur vie sans règles, mais aussi avec une morphologie totalement féminine.
C'est intéressant parce que donc si on part du principe et qu'on tient effectivement à rester très binaire, à dire : « Ben il y a deux sexes et puis c'est tout », mais qu'on
passe ensuite de faire, voilà, une demi-heure de podcast maintenant à discuter des exceptions et des cas un peu spéciaux et de, voilà, de ces filles qui ont deux testicules, qu'ils remarquent au moment de la puberté.
Ça, est-ce que ça n'indique pas finalement qu'on aurait peut-être un petit peu tort d'être aussi binaire et aussi borné dans notre approche ?
Parce que ça m'a fatigué quand vous disiez qu'il y avait 1 ou 2 % de personnes qui sortaient de ce système très binaire XX ou XY.
2 %, c'est quand même beaucoup. Ça veut dire que j'en croise potentiellement tous les jours en prenant le métro. Une question que je pose sans avoir idée de la réponse.
Alors, si on parle de l'orientation sexuelle, qui est tout de même le sujet du jour, là, on est à 5 %, grosso modo, selon toutes les estimations, de gens qui sont atypiques-
Je reviendrai là-dessus, oui
...qui sont homosexuels. Bon. Alors, si on parle de l'identité sexuelle, c'est-à-dire du genre que les gens perçoivent avoir,
on était jusqu'à il y a quelques années avec des statistiques de l'ordre de 1 sur 10 000 à 1 sur 30 000.
Donc c'était extrêmement rare.
Parce que vous disiez 2 %, là, effectivement, c'est-
Oui mais, attendez. Jusqu'à il y a quelques années.
D'accord, OK.
Depuis cinq ans maintenant, on voit apparaître dans la littérature des chiffres qui sont de l'ordre du pour cent, des 5 %.
On voit apparaître des articles aux États-Unis de classes de jeunes de 16, 17 ans qui veulent en groupe changer d'identité sexuelle.
Alors c'est très compliqué parce que est-ce que c'est un phénomène de société ? Est-ce que c'est un phénomène réellement biologique, etc.
? Tout ça est très très compliqué. Les statistiques sont infernales à obtenir puisque les gens ne sont pas toujours honnêtes dans leurs déclarations, évidemment.
Obtenir un échantillonnage représentatif est très difficile. Donc tout ça est associé à des phénomènes extrêmement complexes et sont très difficiles à circonscrire. Donc-
OK
...1, 2 %, c'est probablement un maximum, mais qui sait ce que seront les statistiques dans cinq ans.
Donc conclusion, on est dans le flou, en tout cas pour l'instant et vraisemblablement pendant encore un bon moment.
Je reviens alors sur le deuxième pourcentage que vous avez évoqué il y a un instant où vous disiez personnes homosexuelles, vous disiez 5 %.
Comment est-ce qu'on mesure quelque chose comme ça ?
Ça ne peut jamais être que par questionnaire. De toute façon, il est hors de question d'allonger des gens sur la table et de voir avec qui ils vont s'accoupler.
Donc c'est ce qu'on fait avec les animaux, évidemment. La façon dont le questionnaire est rédigé et les circonstances dans lesquelles il va être administré jouent un rôle extrêmement important dans les résultats qu'on va obtenir.
Les circonstances, bon ben il est clair que les personnes doivent avoir la conviction que les données resteront anonymes.
Donc, on essaye de se mettre dans des circonstances qui vont favoriser cette conviction, mais ça peut varier d'un investigateur à l'autre, ça peut varier d'une étude à l'autre.
Et si vous avez l'impression que votre identité risque d'être révélée, vous serez moins susceptible, probablement, de dévoiler votre homosexualité, puisque c'est quelque chose qui est encore relativement rejeté par la société.
Bon ça, c'est un aspect des choses. L'autre aspect des choses, c'est quand on demande à une personne. On peut demander à une personne : « Êtes-vous homosexuel, bisexuel, hétérosexuel ?
» On peut leur demander de grader leur orientation sexuelle sur une échelle à cinq points ou à sept points comme l'a fait Kinsey.
On peut leur demander s'ils ont déjà eu des rapports homosexuels ou pas, une fois dans toute la vie, une fois dans les quinze derniers jours, une fois dans la dernière année.
Tout ça va donner des pourcentages qui seront relativement différents, évidemment.
Mmh. Et on peut aussi, je suppose, mettre deux individus dans une même pièce et observer comment ils se comportent.
Ça, on n'a jamais fait parce que je crois qu'il y a les comités d'éthique qui ne laisseraient pas passer.
D'accord, OK.
Ce qu'on peut faire par contre-
Comment ça se fait pour le coup ? Enfin, c'est bizarre de regarder, mmh-
Je ne parlais pas d'observer un accouplement sexuel. Je parlais simplement de regarder, je sais pas, les phéromones ou des choses comme ça, l'attraction, le regard, un truc plus soft que...
Ah on pourrait faire ça. Il y a des études qui ont, par exemple, étudié-- on peut traquer le regard, on peut suivre le regard de l'œil avec une caméra
et présenter à un individu des tas d'images qui vont montrer des couples nus, d'un sexe, d'un autre, etc.
Et voir par quel type d'image la personne va être intéressée. Ça, c'est une façon d'objectiver, mais ce n'est pas la même chose que dire : « Je suis attiré par...
» Il y a une autre façon d'objectiver qui est de mesurer les réactions génitales, évidemment. Mesurer l'érection en réponse à un type d'image ou une autre.
Je posais la question parce que les expériences que vous citez partent du principe que toutes les personnes étudiées sont conscientes de leur orientation sexuelle et peuvent s'exprimer là-dessus.
Alors que, ben j'ai personnellement la conviction que beaucoup de gens s'ignorent à ce niveau-là.
Il y a pas mal de gens qui s'ignorent, oui, qui refusent-- il y a pas mal de gens qui refusent de répondre à ce genre de questions également d'ailleurs.
Donc ça, il y a toutes les options et c'est pour ça que la recherche est très difficile.
Pour citer un autre exemple, bon si on prend les mesures d'excitation génitale, bon, on peut faire ce qu'on appelle de la pléthysmographie.
Donc on met un anneau autour du pénis et on présente à un homme des images différentes. Et on va voir s'il va obtenir une érection en voyant des couples nus de sexe masculin ou de sexe féminin.
Cette mesure est en général très bien corrélée avec les déclarations d'orientation sexuelle que la personne fera, homo ou hétéro.
Si vous faites la même expérience chez les femmes, vous remarquerez que les réponses sont totalement indépendantes de l'orientation sexuelle des personnes en question.
Les femmes, qu'elles soient homo ou hétéro, sont sexuellement excitées au niveau du vagin par des images érotiques comprenant aussi bien des hommes que des femmes.
Alors que certaines de ces femmes sont totalement hétérosexuelles et d'autres totalement homosexuelles.
Selon leur dire.
Selon leur dire, oui. Alors, ça veut donc dire-- selon leur dire et leur perception. Alors il y a pas mal d'études qui ont analysé le phénomène et qui montrent donc
cette dissociation chez les femmes qui n'existe pas chez les hommes.
Pourquoi ? De nouveau, on n'a pas la réponse à ce genre de questions, mais c'est très difficile à étudier, évidemment, bon.
Ouais, ouais. Et, mais donc, ce que je remarque, c'est qu'aussi, on est de nouveau ici dans un cas assez binaire, hétérosexuel, homosexuel.
Il existe un phénomène entre les deux qui s'appelle la bisexualité. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est étudié, sur lequel on a des éléments de réponse ?
Est-ce que c'est entre les deux, une-- on est, voilà, on est soumis à des échantillons de testostérone ni trop élevés ni trop bas-
On peut l'imaginer. Disons que dès le départ, quand on a commencé à s'intéresser à l'homosexualité, Alfred Kinsey, qui a publié un premier bouquin sur le sujet en 1948, si je me souviens bien, a déjà
classé les hommes, et puis deux ans plus tard, les femmes, sur une échelle à sept points, donc qui allait-
Vous pouvez l'expliquer cette échelle ?
Oui, donc cette échelle allait de zéro, qui était complètement hétérosexuel, à six, qui était complètement homosexuel. C'est-à-dire : « Je n'ai jamais eu de pensées hétérosexuelles, j'ai jamais eu d'attractions hétérosexuelles.
» Et puis, il avait des un qui étaient des gens qui étaient majoritairement hétéros, mais qui avaient occasionnellement eu des pensées homosexuelles.
Les deux qui avaient plus souvent eu des pensées homosexuelles, qui avaient peut-être fait une expérience, trois, quatre, cinq, etc.
progressivement. Donc on reconnaissait déjà cette variabilité. Et les gens qui étaient à trois, quatre, ben de toute évidence, c'étaient des gens qui étaient bisexuels, puisqu'ils avaient une attraction pour les deux sexes.
Maintenant, vu toutes les difficultés associées à ce genre d'études qu'on vient de mentionner, étudier les subtilités dans l'orientation sexuelle devient extrêmement difficile.
Étudier les extrêmes est déjà horriblement compliqué. Étudier les intermédiaires devient quasiment impossible
tenant compte du fait qu'en plus, dans la majorité des cas chez l'homme en tout cas,
les sujets se retrouvent dans les deux extrêmes, donc ce sont des 0 ou des 1, ou des 5 ou des 6, donc très majoritairement hétéro, très majoritairement homosexuel.
Qu'il y a très peu de cas au milieu. Alors le total, ça fait 5 %, le nombre de cas au milieu, ça va faire 0,1 %, 0,2 %.
Il vous faut un échantillonnage de 3 000 personnes ou de 5 000 personnes avant d'en trouver 20 qui vont être réellement bisexuelles.
Tout ça rend les études très difficiles et donc on n'a quasiment pas de données sur le sujet quoi, pour être précis.
Ce qu'on sait tout de même, mais c'est au niveau phénoménologique, c'est que la bisexualité est beaucoup plus rare chez l'homme que chez la femme.
Vous avez quelque chose qui est avéré. Il y a très peu d'hommes qui se déclarent réellement, se déclarent, hein, toujours la même chose, bisexuels.
Voilà, oui.
Et parmi ceux-ci, ce seront en partie des jeunes qui en fait se rendent compte qu'ils sont pas tout à fait comme les autres
et qui se déclarent bisexuels à un moment donné de leur croissance et de leur évolution cognitive, mais qui, si vous les réinterrogez trois ans plus tard, se déclareront homosexuels.
Ouais, donc on se déclare bisexuel en raison partiellement d'une certaine homophobie, d'une certaine, on ne s'assume pas complètement et on-
Oui ou c'est un, oui, c'est un défaut de s'assumer, de reconnaître réellement son orientation. On trouve ça comme un moyen terme de dire : « Je suis bisexuel ».
Et puis après, ben non, tout compte fait, les femmes ne m'intéressent pas. Chez la femme, par contre, là, on retrouve réellement une incidence de bisexualité.
Donc l'orientation sexuelle des femmes est moins polarisée. C'est très largement démontré et documenté.
Les raisons pour lesquelles ça se produit ne sont pas connues, mais...
J'ai le sentiment en vous écoutant qu'il faut rester assez humble par rapport à nos connaissances à ce niveau-là et qu'il reste beaucoup de questions.
Tout ce qui est biologie et en partie biologie de l'homme, évidemment, on doit rester humble. Bon, on a fait qu'égratigner la surface des phénomènes.
On fait des progrès considérables depuis quelques années avec les techniques d'imagerie médicale qui permettent de voir quelles sont les zones du cerveau qui sont actives quand on fait une chose ou quand on pense à une chose.
Ça permet de progresser, mais tous les phénomènes liés à la sexualité restent très difficiles à étudier parce qu'il y a des inhibitions qui sont présentes dans notre société de façon très claire.
Ouais. Mais donc je note qu'il s'agit, de par ce qu'on a pu étudier, voilà, d'un produit entre d'une part un terrain biologique et hormonal propice-
Ouais
...et en même temps des circonstances, un environnement sociétal, culturel qui permet de, voilà, de s'assumer, de prendre contact avec d'éventuels partenaires et ainsi de suite.
Donc c'est vraiment, ça ne se limite pas à une série d'attributs biologiques.
Le comportement que va adopter l'individu adulte est bien évidemment le résultat de ce qu'il désire. Et ça, à mon sens, c'est probablement largement biologique, mais aussi de ce qu'il va vouloir mettre en action.
Donc le fait de désirer des relations homosexuelles ne veut pas dire que vous allez en avoir. Et si vous décidez d'en avoir, ça, c'est pas un phénomène biologique, probablement, c'est un phénomène cognitif qui est
sous le contrôle de la volonté.
Par ailleurs, le fait de faire son coming out, donc de déclarer publiquement son homosexualité, est de toute évidence un phénomène de société.
Jusqu'à il y a 15, 20 ans, il y avait pas une seule personnalité publique qui était homosexuelle. Et puis maintenant, vous avez des tas de gens-
Un peu plus que 15, 20 ans quand même, je pense à Freddie Mercury.
Oui, oui, bah ça fait plus que 15, 20 ans. Ça fait 30, 40 ans.
Le temps passe vite.
Mais le temps passe vite. Oui, moi, j'ai 70 ans, mais bon, le temps passe vite, effectivement. Mais enfin, si vous voyez les mouvements LGBT aux États-Unis, ça démarre dans les années 60, quelque chose comme ça.
Tout à fait, OK.
Et ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là, mais Bertrand Delanoë, ex-maire de Paris, a déclaré son homosexualité dans les années 80 ou 90, quelque chose comme ça.
Et depuis, il y a eu des tas de gens en vue qui l'ont fait, mais c'est relativement récent. Et ça, ça veut dire que c'est un phénomène de société.
Évidemment, la biologie des individus n'a pas changé depuis les années 60. Donc ça, c'est un phénomène de société. Maintenant, il y a quelque chose-- on ne choisit pas ce qu'on désire, on choisit de mettre ses désirs en action.
Donc ça, c'est quelque chose qui est assez clair dans mon esprit quoi.
Mh, mh, mh.
J'espère que ça l'est pour tout le monde.
C'est sûr.
Il y a une expérience très intéressante qui a été publiée il y a maintenant deux ans par Melissa Hines, qui est
une chercheuse qui travaille à l'Université de Cambridge en Angleterre et qui s'intéresse tout particulièrement
au cas de ces petites filles à hyperplasie des surrénales, donc ces petites filles qui ont été exposées à trop d'androgènes pendant la vie prénatale.
Et en fait, elle a essayé de voir dans quelle mesure ces petites filles, comparées à des petites filles contrôle, étaient sensibles à l'information dite genrée qu'on leur fournit, de l'information concernant le genre-
Oui, oui, oui
...concernant l'identité de genre.
Alors, ce qu'elle a fait, en fait, c'est prendre donc des populations de petites filles à hyperplasie des surrénales et d'autres qui sont contrôle et de leur passer des petits clips vidéo qui duraient deux ou trois
secondes, il y en avait une dizaine chaque fois,
où on voyait un adulte de sexe masculin ou de sexe féminin dire : « Tel jouet est pour les garçons, tel jouet est pour les filles ».
Alors, c'est des jouets qui n'avaient pas de connotation sexuelle au départ. Donc c'était une vache versus un cheval, par exemple.
Mh, mh. D'accord.
Ou alors, on voyait ces adultes qui prenaient un objet, qui pouvait être un piano bleu ou un crayon rouge. Ils le prenaient, mais sans faire de déclaration.
Simplement, l'homme prenait toujours un même objet et la femme prenait toujours un autre objet. L'expérience étant bien entendu contrebalancée de manière à ce que ça ne soit pas des préférences préexistantes qui apparaissaient.
Et alors après ça, on a proposé à ces petites filles qui étaient les sujets de l'expérience, de choisir des objets elles-mêmes, d'une part, ou de déclarer quel objet elles préféraient.
Et on s'est rendu compte que pour les petites filles contrôle, donc les petites filles qui avaient été exposées à des concentrations normales d'androgènes pendant la vie prénatale.
Pour les petites filles contrôle, les vidéos qu'elles avaient vues avaient considérablement influencé leur choix. Et dans à peu près 85 à 90 % des cas, elles choisissaient l'objet qu'elles avaient vu montré par les femmes.
D'accord, ouais.
Ou qu'elles avaient entendu déclarer comme étant des objets de femmes ou de filles.
Donc là, on est en plein dans la question d'éducation, d'émulation, de-
Oui, c'est de l'émulation. C'est même pas de l'éducation parce que c'était pas un apprentissage, c'était juste de l'illustration.
Et par contre, les petites filles à hyperplasie des surrénales, donc qui avaient eu trop d'androgènes, n'avaient pas du tout été sensibles à ces démonstrations et elles choisissaient tout à fait au hasard.
Donc c'était 50-50 grosso modo. Donc ça voulait dire que la testostérone-- ça voudrait dire, si cette expérience est généralisable, parce qu'il n'y en a qu'une dans le domaine, ça voudrait dire que cette testostérone les a rendues
insensibles à l'information de genre qui était fournie par des adultes.
Oui.
Et ça pourrait être une base expliquant comment un mécanisme hormonal relativement simple prénatal pourrait expliquer un comportement relativement complexe qui est de choisir un partenaire d'un sexe ou d'un autre.
Parce que si on n'est pas sensible à l'information de genre, ben on va pas nécessairement se rendre compte que les hommes, c'est pour les femmes et les femmes, c'est pour les hommes quoi.
Donc c'est ça l'idée de l'expérience.
Attendez, attendez, qu'est-ce que...
C'est effectivement assez compliqué.
Ce que vous dites, c'est si on est moins sensible à cette, alors, quel est le mot que je cherche, mais cette émulation, cette imitation.
Imitation genrée.
Voilà, oui, c'est tout à fait ça, oui. À ce moment-là, on est alors, et donc là, on passe sur l'autre plan qui est la question de l'orientation sexuelle.
On soupçonne, on s'interroge sur est-ce qu'on le serait alors également moins en ce qui concerne l'orientation sexuelle ?
Ça, ça n'a pas été étudié, évidemment.
Ça n'a pas été étudié.
Mais c'est quasiment impossible de transposer l'expérience, donc...
Oui, c'est vrai. Sur les petites filles, oui.
Elle est impossible à transposer, l'expérience, mais c'est une extrapolation qu'on peut éventuellement faire. Et alors—
Oui.
...la critique qui avait été faite de cette expérience-là, c'est que c'était un problème de mémoire. C'est que ces petites filles n'avaient pas de mémoire.
Mais si on leur demandait ce qu'elles avaient vu, elles se souvenaient de ce qu'elles avaient vu dans les vidéos, mais elles ne calquaient pas leur comportement sur ce qu'elles avaient vu.
Tout ça est extrêmement complexe, mais on n'a pas beaucoup de données montrant que l'expérience postnatale, disons, l'expérience non biologique postnatale, donc l'expérience sociale, ait une influence sur
l'orientation sexuelle comme je la définis, c'est-à-dire le partenaire qu'on désire, pas le partenaire qu'on va effectivement choisir, hein.
Oui, oui. Mais donc là, vous nous offrez une magnifique transition, donc, de ce premier sujet qu'on a pu explorer, donc, de l'orientation,
de l'orientation sexuelle vers les différences entre les hommes et les femmes, les différences de sexe, mais aussi de genre, par extension.
Dans la préface de ce deuxième livre qui s'appelle Quand le cerveau devient masculin, publié chez Humensciences, donc de l'an dernier, en 2019, vous expliquez que vous publiez ce livre dans un contexte où on a,
dans nos cultures, dans nos sociétés, de plus en plus envie d'effacer les différences entre les hommes et les femmes et qu'on entend de plus en plus un discours qui,
et corrigez-moi si je vous cite mal, hein, mais un discours qui voudrait indiquer que le,
le cerveau des hommes et des femmes est strictement identique et qu'il n'y a pas de différence.
Oui, alors, c'est le contexte dans lequel je publie. Bon, moi, je suis attaché à essayer de montrer ce qu'il y a de biologique en nous.
Alors, ça vient dans un contexte social, évidemment, où il y a des mouvements assez proéminents qui essayent d'obtenir, qui travaillent pour obtenir l'égalité des femmes.
Alors, il est clair qu'historiquement et encore actuellement, les femmes ont été discriminées dans des tas de domaines.
Au niveau de l'éducation, bon, il y a encore des tas de pays du monde où les petites filles ne vont pas à l'école,
mais même dans nos pays, le niveau d'éducation va être éventuellement différent, le type d'occupation va être différent, à travail égal, on n'aura pas salaire égal, etc.
Bon donc, il y a toute une série de discriminations qui affectent encore les femmes.
On sent que vous prenez vos précautions parce qu'on vous a beaucoup embêté. Ça, je le sens.
Oh ben ça, c'est un sujet qui est chaud, tout comme l'autre d'ailleurs. Moi, je travaille que sur des sujets qui sont un peu titillants au niveau sociétal.
Mais bon, c'est pas nécessairement gênant. Donc cette discrimination-là existe. Maintenant, la question est de savoir si cette discrimination est simplement liée au patriarcat et à la dominance masculine
ou si elle reflète des propriétés intrinsèques des cerveaux masculins et féminins qui font que les hommes et les femmes s'intéressent à des choses différentes et donc aboutissent à des endroits différents dans la société.
Ok, c'est intéressant puisque donc on partait de la différence et là, vous vous dirigez tout de suite vers une question beaucoup plus sensible qui est la domination.
Il est clair que les sociétés occidentales, mais la majorité des sociétés, sont des sociétés patriarcales où donc les hommes dominent et dominent les femmes et les ont dominées jusque très récemment, en les empêchant de voter.
C'est sans doute même encore le cas.
C'est encore le cas dans une certaine mesure, mais enfin, ça s'est amenuisé dans nos sociétés. Les femmes peuvent voter, peuvent conduire une voiture.
Les choses vont s'améliorant.
Les choses se sont améliorées. Bon, alors, est-ce qu'elles vont s'améliorer si on continue à se battre dans ce sens-là jusqu'au point où il y aura plus de différence du tout ?
D'une part, est-ce que c'est possible biologiquement et d'autre part, est-ce que c'est désirable ? Désirable, c'est une question de société, mais possible, ça, c'est une question de biologie.
Parce que mon avis, et il est basé sur une littérature assez abondante à nouveau, mon avis est que
ces imprégnations hormonales dont nous avons parlé et des différences génétiques qui sont également préexistantes, il y a quelques centaines de gènes qui s'expriment différentiellement chez les hommes et chez les femmes,
ces différences créent des différences au niveau comportemental qui sont des différences quasiment
impossibles à effacer et qui vont donc induire des intérêts différents, des comportements différents, une agressivité différente, qui explique d'ailleurs le patriarcat dans une certaine mesure. Qui va faire que
les femmes, à mon sens,
n'atteindront jamais la même position que les hommes dans la société. Et d'un autre côté, je pense que ce n'est pas nécessairement désirable parce qu'il y a une richesse à avoir des personnalités différentes dans une même société.
Et je pense, en aparté, que si nos sociétés étaient plus souvent dirigées par les femmes, le monde irait beaucoup mieux.
Ce serait— on aurait des dirigeants beaucoup moins agressifs et le monde irait beaucoup mieux. Mais c'est un grand autre sujet.
Une chose que vous évoquez dans le livre, c'est la corrélation entre la testostérone, les pics d'agressivité et le fait que les populations incarcérées sont très majoritairement des populations mâles.
Donc ça va un petit peu dans ce sens-là aussi de—
Mais oui, disons que de nouveau, c'est une corrélation. Alors, on est toujours dans ce problème quand on fait des études chez l'homme, on est toujours dans ce problème qu'on ne peut pas expérimenter.
On ne peut pas traiter des hommes—
Oui.
...expérimentalement avec de la testostérone, encore que ça se fasse, notamment pour des athlètes style joueurs de football américain.
Bon, ces gens prennent de la testostérone, sont dopés à la testostérone de façon majeure et le nombre d'incidents violents qu'il y a avec ces joueurs est absolument colossal.
Bon, ça, c'est— mais c'est pas une expérience contrôlée, c'est pas une belle expérience. Alors, pour revenir à la corrélation, bon, on sait qu'on peut mesurer l'agressivité de toute une série de façons.
On peut la mesurer physiquement, mais ça se produit tout de même rarement. Mais on peut la mesurer par toute une série de questionnaires qui vont mesurer l'agressivité verbale, l'agressivité potentiellement réelle.
On pose aux gens des questions du genre : si quelqu'un est garé devant votre entrée de garage, un, vous lui demandez gentiment de bouger, deux, vous lui crevez un pneu, trois, vous lui mettez votre poing dans la figure, quoi bon.
Très mal.
Ça dénote des niveaux d'agressivité—
Ouais.
...très différents. Et on se rend compte que toutes ces mesures aboutissent à dire qu'il y a un niveau d'agressivité supérieur chez les hommes que chez les femmes, en moyenne de nouveau, parce qu'il y a énormément de recouvrement.
Mais c'est des recouvrements de courbes. Si on voit les courbes de distribution d'une variable, c'est souvent ce qu'on appelle des courbes en cloche.
Donc, ce sont des espèces de U inversés. Bon, il y a recouvrement entre les deux courbes, mais aux extrêmes, il y a de moins en moins de recouvrement.
Ouais.
Or, si on se rend compte que pour devenir un problème pour la société, pour être foutu en prison, pour le dire,
pour le dire pleinement, il faut avoir
dépassé les bornes de façon tout à fait sérieuse, ben ces individus qui sont à l'extrême de la courbe ont beaucoup plus de probabilités,
j'allais dire de chance, mais c'est pas vraiment une chance, c'est de probabilité dans ce cas-ci, d'être des hommes que des femmes.
Et quand on voit les statistiques d'incarcération pour actes violents dans le monde, il y a deux cent quatre-vingts pays ou deux cent septante-huit pays, je pense.
Il y a trois pays où il y a entre 10 et 15 % de femmes. Et dans tous les autres pays, c'est moins de 10 %. Et même souvent, à partir du trentième pays, c'est moins de 5 % de femmes qui sont incarcérées pour actes violents.
Donc, les femmes sont probablement moins agressives et elles ont moins de problèmes d'agressivité dans la société.
Vous présentez ici donc une explication biologique très claire sur l'importance donc de l'hormone sexuelle mâle, la testostérone.
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas encore une fois ici dans un cas où l'inné et l'acquis travaillent un petit peu main dans la main pour favoriser ces situations-là ?
Oui oui, bien sûr. Et beaucoup plus que dans le cas de l'orientation sexuelle dont on parlait avant. Il est très clair, évidemment, que dès le premier jour de vie, on dit à un petit garçon : « Un petit garçon ne pleure pas.
» Un petit garçon est éduqué de façon différente d'une petite fille et on va quelque part encourager son agressivité alors qu'elle sera plutôt réprimée chez la petite fille.
Ouais. Donc ça, c'est tout le sujet du podcast qu'on avait fait avec Olivia Gazalé sur finalement le mythe de la virilité.
Voilà l'image du soldat violent, costaud, ne se laisse pas affecter par les émotions—
Voilà.
...ne peut pas pleurer et ainsi de suite. Donc ça, c'est— oui, donc on est finalement assez alignés là-dessus sur ces questions de—
Et je pense donc que cette influence de la société et de l'éducation différentielle, qui est de toute évidence donnée aux petits garçons, petites filles, joue un rôle important.
Mais je pense aussi, et les données le suggèrent, que ce rôle important va se greffer sur quelque chose qui était préexistant, qui était beaucoup moins important en amplitude, en
en force, mais qui va se développer suite à cette éducation.
Mais on joue sur un terrain qui est prédéfini, prédéfini ou présensibilisé à un certain type d'influence.
On va se pencher sur donc les, ben c'est finalement le cœur de votre travail, le cerveau humain, la différence entre les hommes et les femmes.
Donc, ce que vous expliquez dans le livre, c'est qu'historiquement, ça a eu une très grande importance en médecine. On pensait pendant très longtemps, vous l'expliquiez, que le cerveau de la femme
était forcément, on pouvait s'en douter, bien plus petit en taille, en masse que celui de l'homme.
Et vous expliquez que ça a changé à partir de, bon déjà à partir de la Renaissance et des dissections. Mais vous parlez de la date de 1976, quand on a fait des expériences sur les canaris.
C'est très amusant.
Ça, c'est intéressant. Bon, oui, à partir de la Renaissance, on se rend compte que les femmes ont un cerveau, évidemment.
Avant ça, on leur déniait même cette existence, hein, mais—
Un cerveau et une âme.
Et un cerveau et une âme. Mais, mais—
donc on se rend compte que c'est grosso modo pareil. Mais alors, et jusque 1976, donc, a vécu le dogme qui disait qu'il n'y avait pas de différence morphologique entre le cerveau d'un mâle et d'une femelle ou d'un homme et d'une femme.
Et puis alors, en fait, c'est des expériences qui ont été réalisées par Fernando Nottebohm et ses collègues à l'université Rockefeller à New York,
qui s'intéressaient à essayer de comprendre les circuits qui contrôlent le chant chez le canari et chez une autre espèce de passereau qu'on appelle le diamant mandarin.
Donc c'est ces oiseaux qui ont des petites joues rouges qu'on voit dans toutes les oiselleries. Et en fait, on sait que chez les diamants mandarins, les mâles chantent abondamment, les femelles ne chantent pas.
Même si on leur met de la testostérone, les femelles ne chanteront jamais. Et par contre chez le canari, ben les femelles chantent beaucoup moins, presque pas, mais si on leur met de la testostérone, elles chantent un petit peu.
Donc il y avait une grosse différence comportementale entre les deux.
Et en cherchant quelles étaient les structures du cerveau qui contrôlaient ces comportements,
ils se sont rendus compte qu'il y avait une différence majeure dans le volume de trois noyaux essentiellement, qui sont des noyaux qui contrôlent le chant
et qui étaient trois fois plus volumineux chez le mâle que chez la femelle, chez les canaris, et cinq fois plus volumineux chez le mâle que chez la femelle, chez le diamant mandarin.
Ce qui était donc la preuve qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle un dimorphisme, une différence de morphologie.
Alors, y a une différence de morphologie, non. Alors, dimorphisme est un terme qui est un petit peu galvaudé parce que dimorphisme, ça veut dire deux formes en grec.
Ouais.
Et en fait, c'est pas vraiment deux formes, mais c'est deux tailles différentes. Donc, on doit plus proprement, à proprement parler, on devrait parler de différence sexuelle plutôt que de dimorphisme sexuel.
Mais tout le monde utilise les termes de dimorphisme sexuel, donc je les utilise encore parfois, par erreur.
Mais enfin, donc y avait une grosse différence sexuelle dans le volume de ces structures et c'était la première fois qu'on voyait ça dans le monde animal, essentiellement, donc, et sans parler de l'homme.
Et donc suite à cette première expérience sur le monde animal, sur les canaris et leurs chants, on a, donc vous l'expliquez, on a fait ensuite des conclusions et des travaux sur le cerveau humain.
Oui, on est d'abord passé par le rat, évidemment, évidemment. Et puis alors, on est passé à l'homme, où on a retrouvé dans le cerveau humain, on a retrouvé également,
par étude histologique post-mortem, toute une série de noyaux qui étaient sexuellement différenciés, c'est-à-dire plus volumineux, soit chez l'homme que chez la femme,
soit chez la femme que chez l'homme, d'ailleurs, parce que le premier exemple, c'était mâle ou homme
plus grand que femme,
mais l'inverse existe également, évidemment.
Ouais. Et alors, ce qui est très intéressant, c'est que donc on, vous le dites, on trouve au total une bonne dizaine de ces noyaux chez l'humain, donc de ces différences...
Trois, quatre bien caractérisés, d'autres qui sont plus ou moins, quoi, oui.
Mais que donc, encore une fois, on en revient à ce qu'on disait sur le rapport de taille entre les doigts tout à l'heure.
Corrélation statistique, mais pas systématique.
Oui.
Alors, on est toujours dans ce problème de la variabilité biologique. Évidemment, si vous avez une différence, c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé la statistique.
Si vous avez une différence, ben elle ne concerne pas toujours tous les individus. Donc y a—
vous aurez, si on prend la taille du noyau de l'aire préoptique, là, qu'on a appelé le noyau numéro 3, ben il est deux fois et demie plus volumineux chez l'homme que chez la femme.
Mais y a des hommes qui ont un noyau plus petit que les femmes qui ont le noyau le plus gros dans leur population.
Donc, vous avez recouvrement, mais le fait qu'il y ait recouvrement ne veut pas dire qu'à la moyenne, y ait pas quelque chose qui se produise et que cette moyenne n'ait un impact en moyenne sur les comportements des individus.
Maintenant, y a des hommes qui sont très féminins, y a des femmes qui sont très masculines. Y a un mélange d'hommes et de femmes en chacun d'entre nous, évidemment.
C'est là que votre livre est particulièrement brillant, je trouve.
C'est cette notion, finalement, de recouvrement statistique sur laquelle je pense qu'on ferait bien de s'attarder, même si vous l'aviez évoqué il y a un instant.
Je repense, quand on parle de ça, donc encore une fois, à ce podcast qu'on avait fait avec Olivia Gazalé sur le, voilà, le mythe de la virilité et toutes ses conséquences.
Elle expliquait, je crois, en fin de podcast que dans nos cultures occidentales, on est finalement très binaire et très, voilà, deux polarités, l'homme, la femme.
Et finalement, quand je lis votre livre et qu'on se penche sur les différences morphologiques ou peu importe le terme qu'on va employer, du cerveau, on voit que ça n'est pas tellement binaire que ça.
Ça n'est pas deux polarités, enfin...
Mais j'aime bien qu'on garde le terme de binarité parce qu'il y a tout de même deux sexes. Maintenant, ceci étant, toutes les caractéristiques dans un individu ne vont pas être des caractéristiques masculines et inversement.
Y a d'ailleurs une chercheuse israélienne qui s'appelle Daphna Joel, qui a publié quelques articles récemment, qui avait fait pas mal de bruit, où elle dit que tous les cerveaux sont des mosaïques de caractéristiques masculines et féminines.
C'est vrai dans une certaine mesure, mais la balance va tout de même pencher plus pour les caractéristiques masculines chez l'homme et inversement chez les femmes.
Et elle avait mis au point un outil statistique qui permettait de, qui aurait soi-disant dû permettre de séparer les cerveaux masculins et les cerveaux féminins.
Elle n'y arrivait pas, mais d'autres chercheurs ont répondu à cet article en disant : « Si, si, il suffit de modifier un petit peu les critères de sélection et vous aurez des cerveaux masculins et des cerveaux féminins.
» Maintenant, ce n'est pas du blanc et du noir.
Voilà.
Voilà, c'est— y a toujours des niveaux de gris entre les deux et c'est pour tout en biologie. C'est vrai pour les différences sexuelles, mais c'est vrai aussi pour tout autre type de différence.
Et c'est vrai dans la vie courante. Moi, l'exemple que je prends vraiment, c'est quelle est la différence entre une chaise et un fauteuil ?
Je vous défie de trouver une définition. Y a qu'un critère qui définit chaise et fauteuil, parce que la présence des accoudoirs n'est pas nécessairement discriminante.
La présence de l'aspect confortable, les fauteuils de Hervé qu'on avait dans le temps dans le pays ici, sur des fauteuils en bois, étaient pas confortables du tout.
Donc y a pas un critère, mais grosso modo, les gens reconnaîtront tout de même ce que c'est un fauteuil et une chaise et les gens reconnaîtront dans la majorité des cas ce que c'est un homme et une femme.
Donc, je pense que la binarité est une notion à laquelle je tiens, étant entendu que la frontière entre les deux n'est pas toujours coupée au couteau, quoi.
C'est tout à fait ça. Et c'est ce qu'expliquait Olivia Gazalé, c'est qu'elle estime que la philosophie, donc des pays orientaux, du yin et du yang, avec
du noir avec du blanc dedans et inversement, du blanc avec du noir dedans, est plus féconde.
Et cette idée de dire que les hommes ont une part de féminité, les femmes ont une part de masculinité, est plus pertinente que cette idée beaucoup plus binaire et beaucoup plus...
Tranchée, ouais, la différence tranchée entre les sexes, oui. Bien sûr, mais de nouveau, la normalité, c'est-à-dire la norme statistique, veut qu'il y ait des courbes qui sont séparées et qui,
pour certains critères, sont très différentes.
Bon, si vous prenez la
Les structures génitales, bon c'est très très différent. Si vous prenez la taille, ben les hommes sont 10, 15 centimètres plus grands que les femmes en moyenne, mais y a des recouvrements, y a des grandes femmes bien entendu, etc.
Mais bon, voilà. La présence de seins, c'est une caractéristique féminine, mais si les hommes mangent un peu trop d'œstradiol, ben ils vont avoir des seins qui vont se développer.
Vous avez tous ces intermédiaires, évidemment, hein.
C'est finalement un choix entre se focaliser sur la moyenne ou se focaliser sur le fait que la moyenne n'est pas la règle.
Oui, mais il faut prendre les deux. Bon, quand on fait une étude scientifique, on étudie les différences à la moyenne, mais on étudie aussi la variance entre les individus à l'intérieur de chaque groupe.
Et c'est là que réside la difficulté à comprendre que des différences avec recouvrement ont néanmoins des conséquences au niveau sociétal, par exemple.
Si on s'intéresse aux comportements humains, c'est très très difficile de sortir la part de l'inné puisqu'il faudrait pouvoir tester les enfants au premier jour de vie, évidemment, avant toute influence sociale.
L'humain est un animal fondamentalement social, embuyé dans une société.
Social. Il a un développement qui est extrêmement long. Il naît avec un cerveau qui est complètement immature et qui se développe pendant les 20, 30 premières années de vie et qui donc est extrêmement influencé par tout ce-
Malléable.
...par toutes les expériences, etc. Bon, tout ça ne doit pas être rejeté, évidemment. Mais on retrouve des petites différences dès le premier jour de vie.
Et ces petites différences vont s'amplifier en fonction de l'éducation différentielle. Et même si l'éducation était identique, elle s'amplifierait.
Parce que si vous avez une petite différence de perception du monde, le monde que vous allez voir n'est pas le même en fonction de vos différences de base.
Personne ne vit dans le même monde. Un petit garçon, une petite fille qui naissent dans la même maison ne vivent pas dans le même monde parce qu'ils voient des choses différentes, ils s'intéressent à des choses différentes.
Et donc, ils vont évoluer de plus en plus différentiellement en fonction de différences préexistantes qui étaient éventuellement minimes.
Et c'est ça qui est très difficile à appréhender dans l'espèce humaine, évidemment.
Ouais, et donc quand on parle alors de ces différences à un très jeune âge, vous expliquez qu'il y a eu des expériences sur les animaux, sur les primates, en l'occurrence,
pour leur rapport à certaines couleurs, à certains jouets et que donc on peut tirer des conclusions alors sur les humains.
Oui, enfin, on peut tirer des conclusions, on extrapole aux humains. Bon, de nouveau, c'est cette histoire des jouets.
Alors, les préférences de jouets chez les petits enfants, c'est quelque chose qui a fort marqué la presse aussi.
Oui.
Chez les petits enfants, donc, de quatre, cinq ans, vous leur donnez le choix entre des jouets qui sont des jouets mobiles de type garçon, des ballons, des voitures, etc.
Ou des peluches et des éléments de dînette et des choses comme ça. Vous vous rendez compte que
majoritairement et à la moyenne de nouveau, c'est pas chez tout le monde, mais les garçons prendront les jouets de garçon, les filles prendront les jouets de fille.
Alors tout le monde est persuadé que c'est uniquement un phénomène d'éducation et de société, mais y a deux arguments qui suggèrent que ce n'est pas le cas.
Pas uniquement le cas.
D'une part, il y a ces expériences sur les singes. Donc il y a
deux expériences indépendantes qui ont été réalisées sur des espèces de singes différentes dans des labos différents et qui montrent que ce genre de préférence est déjà présent chez le singe.
Donc ça veut dire que le mâle est attiré par ce qui bouge, etc.
Alors que la femelle moins. C'est un aspect des choses. L'autre aspect des choses, c'est de nouveau l'étude de ces petites filles exposées à trop d'androgènes de façon prénatale qui montrent des préférences pour les jouets de garçon.
Et ça, ça a été très très bien documenté par Melissa Hines aussi. Donc, une préférence pour les jouets de garçon et une perte d'intérêt pour les jouets de fille.
Donc là, c'est vraisemblablement la testostérone prénatale à nouveau, puisque ces petites filles ont été élevées comme filles depuis la naissance.
Oui.
Alors, les parents savaient évidemment qu'il y avait eu un problème hormonal en prénatal. Et on peut toujours imaginer, les psychologues disent : « Oui, mais ces petites filles n'ont pas été élevées normalement. »
C'est-à-dire que si leur nature, c'est de ne pas être très réceptive aux rôles genrés, aux règles qu'elles doivent suivre et ainsi de suite, on peut imaginer une différence dans le développement.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'on aurait justement, si elles ne sont pas très réceptives à tout ça, ben on pourrait se dire qu'elles sont parfaitement neutres...
Oui, en fait, elles ne sont pas neutres, elles sont plus du côté masculin que du côté féminin, de ce côté-là.
Mais comment est-ce qu'on explique ?
Ah ben, on l'explique par la testostérone prénatale, évidemment. Et si vous faites évidemment la même expé-- alors on peut pas faire la même expérience avec des mammifères non humains parce que,
bon, ils ne jouent pas avec des jouets, mais il y a des tas de comportements qui sont masculinisés par la testostérone prénatale.
Alors, ça peut être des comportements d'exploration. Bon, on dit que les hommes savent mieux lire les cartes, les femmes savent pas lire les cartes.
Bon, c'est pas du tout rien de nouveau. Y a une légère différence dans l'orientation tridimensionnelle, mais vous retrouvez cette différence chez le rat et vous pouvez la manipuler par les hormones prénatales.
Donc ça veut dire que dans ce modèle animal, vous avez quelque chose qui correspond à ce qui est chez l'homme.
Maintenant, est-ce qu'on peut extrapoler de l'animal à l'homme ? Ben y a des gens qui diront oui, des gens qui diront non.
Les biologistes vous diront oui, les psychologues ont plutôt tendance à vous dire non.
Et vous êtes biologiste.
Et je suis biologiste.
Ouais, ouais. Oh oui, alors donc on parlait alors des jouets et au niveau des couleurs.
Y a une autre expérience, et je ne sais pas si elle a été reproduite, celle-là, qui est une expérience qui a été réalisée au Japon,
où on a de nouveau comparé des petits garçons et petites filles et des petites filles qui étaient exposées à trop de testostérone en prénatal.
Et alors, ce qu'ont fait les expérimentateurs-là, c'est donner à tous ces enfants une boîte de crayons de couleur neuve et leur proposer de dessiner pendant deux heures.
Et alors, on s'est rendu compte qu'au bout de deux heures, ben les garçons dessinaient de nouveau des camions, des voitures et tout ça.
Les petites filles dessinaient des papillons, des fleurs, des personnages. Et les filles CH dessinaient les camions. Enfin, pour schématiser, c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Et alors, l'autre aspect dans les couleurs, c'est que les chercheurs les ont laissés jouer même pas mal de temps et ils avaient un taille-crayon.
C'était des enfants de cinq à sept ans. Ils avaient des taille-crayons, donc ils pouvaient tailler les crayons qui s'usaient.
Et puis, ils ont mesuré la longueur des crayons restants à la fin de l'étude.
Et ils se sont rendu compte que les garçons avaient beaucoup plus utilisé, et ça se voyait sur les dessins d'ailleurs, les couleurs froides, c'est-à-dire le bleu et le vert,
et les filles avaient beaucoup plus utilisé les couleurs chaudes, c'est-à-dire l'orange et le,
et le rose, etc.
Est-ce que vous seriez d'accord si, sur base de ces expériences, que je supputais l'idée qu'on a donc une certaine part de nature innée chez d'une part les hommes, d'autre part les femmes qui
les amènent dans des directions différentes.
Donc dans ce cas-ci, voilà, des jouets plutôt humains, des visages, de l'empathie, des personnages. Et dans le cas des hommes, des garçons plutôt donc des petites voitures, des objets mobiles et ainsi de suite.
Et que donc ça, c'est la moyenne, mais que ce n'est pas systématique, mais que cette moyenne a amené ensuite,
la construction de règles, de rôles genrés pour dire : bah oui, les garçons préfèrent les petites voitures, ils préfèrent le bleu.
Bah oui, les petites filles préfèrent les poupées, préfèrent le rose. Et qu'on a ensuite donc bien cimenté, bien gravé ces règles dans le marbre
sans tenir compte de, bah ce que vous expliquiez tout à l'heure, c'est qu'il y a un certain recouvrement
et que ça ne concerne pas 100 % de la population des hommes, ça ne concerne pas 100 % de la population des femmes et que ces choses-là sont un peu plus-
Plus malléables.
...malléables, un peu plus fluides que-
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Mais je n'essaye pas de dire dans mon livre et dans cette interview que les hommes sont radicalement différents des femmes.
Je dis qu'il y a des petites différences biologiques qui sont présentes et qu'elles ont des conséquences et qu'elles ont notamment eu des conséquences au niveau de la structuration de la société.
Oui.
Mais pour prendre un ex-- et qui peuvent être déconstruites dans une certaine mesure aussi. Bon, pour reprendre un exemple relativement simple, y a jamais eu de championnat de football ou de rugby féminin
jusqu'à relativement récemment.
Alors, je ne sais pas jusqu'où il faut remonter, mais si on remonte à 30, 40 ans, je suis sûr qu'il y avait pas de club de rugby féminin.
C'est pas à moi qu'il faut demander.
Bah oui. Et maintenant, il y a des clubs de rugby féminin. Donc il y a des filles qui ont envie de jouer au rugby. Alors est-ce que ces filles sont-
C'est aussi à mettre dans un contexte d'émancipation féminine qui a beaucoup changé ces 50 dernières années.
Bien sûr, mais c'est la déconstruction des schémas traditionnels qui avaient été construits, qui, à mon avis, se basaient sur quelque chose de biologique
assez ténu, mais qui avait été cimenté, coulé dans le béton et qui maintenant est en train de se déconstruire dans une certaine mesure.
Ouais.
Je n'ai aucun problème avec ça, évidemment, mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas non plus jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain et dire : y a rien de biologique dans ce que nous sommes, parce que je pense que c'est un mélange des deux.
Ce que j'ai l'impression que ce que nous sommes en train de dire, c'est que ces règles, ces rôles genrés sont indirectement ou-
Partiellement.
...vous voyez, la conséquence de-
De différences de nature.
Oui, voilà.
Oui, c'est ça. Bah, on est tout à fait d'accord. Je crois qu'on est sur la même longueur d'onde.
Très bien. Mais c'est assez fascinant.
Rien n'est inné, rien n'est acquis. Hein, bon, c'est très très clair. C'est une distinction d'ailleurs qui a fait ra-- un combat qui a fait rage parmi les éthologistes, donc les gens qui étudient le comportement animal.
Dans les années 40 et 50, bon, il y avait une grosse opposition entre les éthologistes européens, Konrad Lorenz, Niko Tinbergen, etc., qui étaient des partisans des comportements innés.
Et puis, aux États-Unis, il y avait l'école behavioriste de Skinner, etc.
Et, mais ils ont fini par tous se rejoindre en se disant : bah en fait, on a tous raison.
Oui, ils se sont rejoints. Moi, j'ai deux, trois papiers qui datent du milieu des années 60 dans mon bureau qui disent : ou en fait, bon, c'est les deux quoi.
Ouais.
Et c'est tellement évident. Mais quand on parle de l'homme, on n'arrive pas du tout à faire passer cette idée-là, en tout cas dans nos pays.
Je crois qu'aux États-Unis, ça passe relativement bien. En France, ça passe très mal.
Donc, si on se repenche maintenant sur, donc le, on parlait, voilà, de différences comportementales, des choix de jouets, des choix de couleurs et ainsi de suite.
Si on se repenche sur le, voilà, un niveau plus micro qui est peut-être sans doute plus votre spécialité, on a longtemps dit, et à vous de me dire si c'est toujours d'actualité, on a longtemps dit que
les hommes, voyez, visualisaient mieux en 3D, se situaient mieux dans l'espace, que les femmes étaient sans doute meilleures pour la linguistique, pour les langues.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité derrière ça ? Est-ce que c'est-
Oui, oui. Là, y a une vérité, et c'est, bon, la différence
de vision dans l'espace et de ce qu'on appelle les rotations tridimensionnelles, c'est-à-dire retrouver des obje-- on a deux objets qui sont des objets miroirs,
on fait tourner l'un par rapport à l'autre et on demande si les objets sont identiques ou ne sont pas identiques quoi.
Les hommes réalisent ces tâches mieux que les femmes en moyenne. Et dans les tâches cognitives, c'est probablement celle qui est la plus différenciée, donc la plus,
où on retrouve le plus, de façon la plus reproductible, une différence homme-femme.
Donc ça, c'est bien établi. La corrélation avec le cerveau derrière, par contre, on n'a pas idée de quelles sont les-- pourquoi cette différence est présente.
Mais la différence est là. Les tâches langagières, tout ce qui est vocabulaire, trouver des synonymes, trouver des mots commençant par une lettre donnée, etc.
Les femmes ont une légère supériorité aux hommes à ce niveau-là. Et alors, c'est assez amusant parce qu'on peut se demander de nouveau est-ce que c'est langue, est-ce que c'est inné/acquis.
Et alors, y a une étude qui m'a particulièrement intéressé, qui est sortie il y a maintenant cinq, six ans dans Science.
C'est une étude qui étudiait les différences d'aptitude verbale et d'aptitude mathématique des garçons et des filles dans une vingtaine de pays, dans mon souvenir-
Des filles de quel âge ?
Alors, c'était des enfants en âge de, ça devait être en âge de fin d'école secondaire, quelque chose comme ça. Donc c'était des-
Quasi des adultes quoi.
Quasi des adultes. Bon. Alors,
on retrouve-- et c'était fait, mais alors ce qui était intéressant, c'est que c'était fait dans une trentaine, vingt, trente pays qui ont des niveaux d'éducation différentielle des filles qui sont assez variables quoi.
Il y a des pays où les filles font très peu d'études, des pays-
D'accord.
...occidentaux, où ils en font beaucoup. On s'est rendu compte que, et il y avait une évolution dans le temps. On s'est rendu compte que,
bon les garçons, dans les pays où les filles étaient défavorisées dans les études anciennes, les garçons étaient meilleurs pour les tâches mathématiques et les filles meilleures pour les tâches verbales.
Quand l'éducation des filles progressait, que ce soit parce qu'on change de pays ou qu'on bouge dans le temps, la différence en mathématiques disparaissait, avait même tendance à s'inverser légèrement.
Par contre, la différence en influence verbale augmentait.
Ce qui signifie que la différence en mathématiques était probablement liée à des différences d'éducation, simplement,
mais que la différence verbale était présente au départ et masquée partiellement par une éducation inférieure et qu'elle s'amplifiait quand on éduquait mieux les filles.
Et ça, c'est un aspect de l'étude qui n'est jamais mentionné par personne. On dit les différences disparaissent quand on donne aux filles l'occasion de faire des études.
Et en fait, dans cette expérience-là, la différence mathématique, oui, disparaissait, mais la différence vocabulaire ne disparaissait pas, la différence langagière.
Ce qui suggère qu'y a peut-être quelque chose qui est là. Mais on est de nouveau dans des études corrélatives et qui sont-- bon, y a des interprétations alternatives.
Ouais, donc je note vraiment ce besoin d'être très prudent. Et donc, à la question innée ou acquis, la réponse est comme presque à chaque fois-
C'est les deux.
Ou c'est les deux, on ne sait pas vraiment, c'est compliqué.
Et dans tout ce qui est tâche cognitive complexe, c'est beaucoup d'acquis, évidemment. Y a des expériences très très éclairantes qui ont été faites à ce niveau-là,
et c'était notamment des expériences qui concernaient des tests de géométrie.
En fait, si on dit à des filles, à des garçons d'ailleurs, qu'on va leur faire faire un test de géométrie, les garçons réussissent mieux que les filles dans nos sociétés en général.
Mmh. Oui.
Si par contre, on leur dit qu'on va leur faire faire un test de dessin, alors y a pas de différence, voire les filles sont supérieures aux garçons.
Donc, le contexte dans lequel on va placer l'étude
va avoir une influence énorme, ce qui est un des arguments pour faire dire aux gens qui sont des négationnistes de la biologie : « Vous voyez, c'est uniquement une question de conditionnement social, etc. »
Oui.
Et c'est en partie une question de conditionnement social, nous sommes tout à fait d'accord, mais y a plus que ça derrière, à mon avis.
Et c'est justement un élément que je trouve très intéressant dans ce livre. En fin de livre, vous évoquez l'idée de, ben l'éducation différée selon le sexe de l'enfant.
Et vous expliquez, ben c'est en fait, ça n'est pas que chez les hommes qu'on trouve ça. Et vous expliquez que chez les rats, les jeunes ratons sont élevés un petit peu différemment selon leur sexe.
Ah oui, bien sûr. Ben l'influence-- bon, on dit toujours chez l'homme, y a l'acquis et y a l'inné, et puis chez-- ou on doute de l'inné, puis chez le rat, c'est tout de l'inné.
Mais en fait, non, y a des formes de culture chez les animaux et on s'en rend compte de plus en plus au fur et à mesure de l'évolution de la biologie et de l'éthologie.
Y a aussi une forme d'éducation différentielle des petits garçons et des petites filles ou des petits rats et des petites rates.
Alors, les expériences que je rapporte là-bas, c'est des expériences qui ont été réalisées à l'Université de Boston, en fait, dans les années 60, 70.
Déjà, c'est des vieilles expériences qui ont été continuées d'ailleurs et beaucoup raffinées. Mais la base du phénomène est la suivante, c'est que les mères, en fait, les rates,
lèchent la région anogénitale de leur raton, de leur petit nouveau-né, pour les inciter à déféquer, en fait, et à uriner.
C'est une stimulation qui est nécessaire. Et en fait, elles le font beaucoup plus sur les ratons mâles que sur les ratons femelles.
Alors, on se dit pourquoi ? Ben au niveau proximal, c'est très facile. En fait, les ratons mâles, ils émettent une odeur qui stimule les mères.
Si on rend les mères anosmiques, donc si on leur bloque le fonctionnement du nez, elles ne font plus de distinction entre les ratons mâles et les ratons femelles.
Et par ailleurs, si on castre les ratons mâles, on leur enlève leur testostérone, ils n'ont plus cette odeur. Et de nouveau, les ratons mâles et les ratons femelles sont traités de la même façon.
Mais ce qu'il y a de plus intéressant, c'est que ces ratons mâles qui reçoivent donc une stimulation anogénitale importante,
chez ces ratons, donc, ces stimulations sont importantes dans le développement du comportement sexuel ultérieur.
Et si on les prive de cette stimulation,
c'est-à-dire si on les rend anosmiques ou si on rend les mères anosmiques ou si on enlève l'odeur chez les ratons mâles, ben ils vont développer un comportement sexuel qui sera partiellement déficient à l'âge adulte.
Donc ce traitement différentiel des petits ratons mâles et femelles a un impact sur le développement du comportement.
Donc ça, c'est un exemple d'effet d'éducation différentiel qui est présent chez les animaux et qui a des conséquences dans la vie adulte.
Ça me surprend parce que je voulais aborder cette question en pensant qu'il s'agissait là de quelque chose de très instinctif, inné, de voilà, qui s'explique par les hormones.
Mais vous avez commencé en expliquant qu'il y avait une forme de culture chez les rats. Et ça, ça m'a vraiment surpris.
Alors oui, culture, c'est peut-être pas tellement chez les rats, mais y a des traditions qui se propagent dans les sociétés animales.
Alors, le premier exemple clair qui a été publié ou mis en évidence, c'était celui de ces singes laveurs de pommes de terre, là.
En fait, y a des groupes de singes au Japon qu'on nourrissait avec des, je crois que c'était des patates, des pommes de terre, qu'on leur jetait dans le sable.
C'est des singes qui vivent au bord d'une rivière. Et on leur donnait des pommes de terre et ils les mangeaient, ils les frottaient un petit peu, ils bouffaient plein de sable avec leurs pommes de terre.
Et puis y a une femelle, un jour, qui a eu l'idée de tremper sa pomme de terre dans l'eau, dans l'eau de la rivière, ce qui la nettoyait évidemment, et qui a mangé sa pomme de terre beaucoup plus efficacement.
Et cette tradition s'est transmise progressivement de femelle en femelle, puis de femelle en mâle. Donc, y avait un ordre hiérarchique dans la transmission.
Et maintenant, toute la troupe de singes en question utilise cette technique. Mais ça, c'est le premier exemple qui a été démontré.
Cet exemple-là, effectivement, le singe est un cousin de l'homme, ou pour ainsi dire.
L'apprentissage du chant chez les oiseaux chanteurs, chez les passereaux, c'est une forme de culture puisqu'ils apprennent le chant de leurs parents-
Mmh.
...et ils apprennent le dialecte local.
Donc si on isole un oisillon de ses parents et qu'on arrive à l'élever, à le nourrir de manière un petit peu en laboratoire-
Il n'aura jamais un chant qui correspond au chant de l'adulte.
Donc c'est fascinant de voir que finalement, cette dichotomie entre inné et acquis ne concerne pas que l'homme. La culture n'est pas que le propre de l'homme, mais qu'on retrouve ça chez l'animal aussi.
Bien sûr. Et si on reprend le chant, y a en fait une prédisposition innée à apprendre certains chants, parce que si vous élevez un pinson en présence d'un moineau domestique, ben il apprendra pas.
Donc, y a une prédisposition innée à apprendre qui implique aussi qu'il y ait toute une structure génétiquement déterminée, des noyaux de contrôle du chant, etc.
Mais après, y a un apprentissage, donc y a une accumulation d'inné et d'acquis dans ce comportement-là, comme dans pratiquement tous les comportements animaux et humains.
La part de l'acquis étant bien entendu plus importante chez l'homme vu la complexité de son cerveau.
C'est tout à fait fascinant. On s'approche tout doucement, même largement, de la fin de cet épisode.
On va peut-être conclure sur quelque chose que vous évoquez dans votre livre. Pour en revenir sur le contexte dans lequel vous le publiez,
vous estimez qu'on est finalement aujourd'hui dans une ère de post-vérité et que aujourd'hui, le rapport à la science a changé ?
Ah, j'ai malheureusement l'impression que la population en général fait de moins en moins confiance à la science pour résoudre les problèmes de société ou voire même les problèmes techniques.
Bon, y a une négation de ce que sont les données scientifiques et les consensus scientifiques qui est évidente dans pas mal de domaines.
Un des domaines, dans le domaine médical, par exemple, y a tous ces mouvements anti-vaccination qui se sont développés, qui sont bien connus de tout le monde.
C'est un des aspects. Y a une fascination pour les médecines dites parallèles qui sont basées sur des connaissances qui sont en général des croyances, des superstitions, etc.
Et qui ne recouvrent absolument pas la connaissance scientifique actuelle, le cas le plus évident étant celui de l'homéopathie, qui est basée sur des principes qui n'ont aucune rationalité, mais qui sont malgré tout extrêmement,
extrêmement répandus.
Bon, dans un autre domaine, dans le domaine des changements climatiques, y a une espèce de consensus actuel du groupe du GIEC pour dire que le climat se réchauffe.
Ça, tout le monde est à peu près d'accord pour l'accepter, encore que ça se discute malgré tout.
Mais en plus pour dire que l'influence anthropique, l'influence de l'homme est probablement impliquée, même si y a jamais de vérité scientifique, on ne sait jamais rien démontrer, mais ce sont des modèles mathématiques qui convergent.
On vient de retester quinze modèles mathématiques qui dataient des années 80 et ces modèles tenaient à peu près tous la route à l'heure actuelle.
Donc il semblerait qu'il y ait quand même quelque chose de réel là-dedans. Les gens le nient, enfin une partie de la population le nie, le nie de façon très nette.
Donc y a une défiance vis-à-vis de la science. Y a eu des erreurs commises, bien évidemment.
Oui, on a évoqué la taille du cerveau féminin.
La science n'est pas un phénomène parfait,
mais c'est heureusement un phénomène autocorrecteur. Ça veut dire que quand y a un problème, il finit presque toujours, si le problème est important, en tout cas, il finit presque toujours par être détecté et corrigé.
Donc ce qui corrige la mauvaise science, c'est de la meilleure science, c'est pas des croyances, des rites et l'opinion, une opinion entendue sur Internet.
Alors, on aurait pu croire il y a quelques années que l'existence de l'Internet et la facilité de distribution de l'information allait augmenter la connaissance au niveau de la population générale.
Et on peut craindre que malheureusement, ça ne soit pas le cas et que ce soit le contraire qui se produise. Et les idées erronées ont tendance à se propager beaucoup plus rapidement que les idées correctes.
Ça a d'ailleurs été étudié quantitativement et les rumeurs fausses se répandent beaucoup plus vite que les idées vraies.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Et donc c'est assez inquiétant parce qu'on est en train de perdre quelque chose qui avait été acquis par les sociétés occidentales, qui était le rapport à la rationalité.
Mh.
Et c'est en train de-
L'argument d'autorité, finalement.
Et l'argument d'autorité finit par avoir plus d'importance. Et malheureusement, ce ne sont pas toujours les gens les plus malins qui ont l'autorité quoi.
Le consensus scientifique, qui n'est pas un argument d'autorité, qui est un consensus scientifique, c'est-à-dire c'est l'état des connaissances jusqu'à preuve du contraire,
eh ben ce consensus scientifique n'est plus aussi respecté qu'il l'était y a une vingtaine d'années ou vingt ou trente ans, probablement.
J'essaie d'apporter ma petite pierre à la
connaissance générale parce que ce
sont des données, tout ce qu'il y a dans ces deux bouquins, c'est des données qui sont largement accessibles, mais elles sont accessibles en langue anglaise pour la grande majorité et en langue française, elles ne sont pas disponibles.
Et donc, je pense que je joue un rôle utile. Enfin, j'espère jouer un rôle utile, en tout cas, en diffusant ces connaissances.
Jacques Balthazart, merci beaucoup pour ces un peu plus que septante minutes passées ensemble dans ce podcast.
Je vous remercie pour votre participation.
Merci bien.
Au revoir. Merci d'avoir écouté jusqu'au bout. J'ai vraiment hâte d'avoir vos retours sur cette émission. Vous pouvez nous écrire à moi ou à Jacques Balthazart sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Je rappelle aussi que le premier livre dont nous avons parlé aujourd'hui s'appelle Biologie de l'homosexualité : on naît homosexuel, on ne choisit pas de l'être.
Et le second, qui est sans doute plus abordable si on n'est pas un féru de science, s'appelle Quand le cerveau devient masculin.
J'ai appris beaucoup de choses en lisant et en discutant avec le professeur. J'espère que ça a été votre cas aussi. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast, de nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et quant à moi, je vous retrouve dans deux semaines. À très bientôt. Salut !